voici Jonathan Moov
pourquoi tu es là
[Musique]
ta commis un meurtre bien est-ce que
quelqu'un t'a brisé le coeur est-ce que
tu m'as brisé le coeur
Maria
vous pousse toujours à trouver un
nouveau chemin
tu te trompes maman sujet je vais te
prouver que
[Musique]
je dois faire profil bas
il s'avère qu'enseigner c'est sympa et
que Londres c'est pas si mal je suis
tombé sur les personnes les plus folles
et les plus abîmées de la terre un
cercle de blaireau privilégié
ça manque d'avoir quelqu'un quelque part
salut non non ça ne m'intéresse pas non
ça ne m'intéresse pas je ne veux pas
savoir
[Musique]
pourquoi il m'arrive toujours ce genre
de truc la police enquête désormais sur
un deuxième meurtre parmi la haute
société il l'appelle le tueur bouffeur
de richesse
[Musique]
tu crois que c'est un de mes amis le
tueur allez arrête de jouer les
détectives
tous les mobiles se résument toujours au
sexe au fric ou à la vengeance
[Musique]
c'est pour fuir tout ça que je suis
parti
mais l'un d'entre vous m'observe
[Musique]
l'un de vous est un monstre qui se cache
en pleine lumière Alors c'est lequel
d'entre vous
[Musique]
si jamais tu me voles la vedette je te
jure que je te dis
tout ce que je veux c'est reprendre le
cours de mes petites vacances
européennes
[Musique]